you're about to get your first taste
field go treat the case bring it back to
your safe zone that last round was not
EP I just saw an opening and I ran to
the finish line we defeated team hot we
beat them by at least a minute and 30
seconds we kind of got our butts kicked
last words for team how are you going
down I got a plan am I get us both
killed but if it works it'll be a
totally boss story cool oh it was not
cool all right final mission my pump for
the final round yeah some pump for the
final round I think this is the round
run finally get to jump on the top of
the car and just Rambo everybody I am
feeling great about the final mission
right now it's team heart against team
Johnson head-to-head round I am
definitely more nervous same objective
retrieve the case and bring it back to
your starting point my strategy this
time would be to work with a team as
best as possible and to lead them into
battle let's get to our starting place
no trophies for second place
the main tactic we used is we wanted to
go in and do it quick play it safe I got
my phone out and I kind of set it down
on the ground so the camera was peeking
around the corner I could see when
people were coming some people might
call it cheating I call strategy don't
go go get cover being on your own and
kind of having to fend for yourself it
was very tough I'm the guy I'm gonna
handle this well we're gonna kill her
alright guys bring it on me in the world
of international espionage things aren't
always what they seem so right now
you're two teams but really you need to
be one it's you guys against us man like
come on you can't be serious okay great
this is gonna go real well nope go ahead
and move up move up I want to be honest
I kind of just through all the training
up window it's like as soon as I see
anything I'm firing this I was still
kind of game planning my strategy I got
shot in the neck my turn was over before
it even started
I turned a corner and I ran into two
with them and I took a few rounds boom
boom boom right between the eyes we
definitely didn't stand a chance I knew
that from the moment they said we're up
against them hey Kim your mags move up
coming up close
move up the back wall is clear clear got
blown away physically emotionally
mentally you can tell by the looks of my
arm that I went in and I went it hot it
definitely stings but at the end of the
day it's like look at my cool battle
wound excellent work today I'm actually
seriously impressed with everybody here
put the bar right here and you got about
right there but this was your
expectation and you beat it okay I did
successfully complete the training it
feels good I feel like I've actually
accomplished something with my life mom
if you're watching try to be proud of me
for a change please great job guys now I
need you to get the way here huh okay
you